vous le savez certainement elle
s'appelle amandine elle est née hier
matin à l'hôpital antoine béclère à
clamart c'est le premier bébé éprouvette
français et nous à l'île de france nous
avons suivi les travaux de l'équipe de
l'hôpital antoine béclère depuis un an
je vous propose de suivre ce soir un
document exclusif réalisé par agnès de
la fac dans ce service ce document n'est
pas une simulation
il s'agit d'une fécondation in vitro
film et il y a un peu plus de neuf mois
à clamart
voici comment se passe l'opération fiv
est avec ses différentes phases le
prélèvement de l'ovule s'effectue au
cours d'une intervention sous anesthésie
générale par coelioscopie on introduit
dans le nombril à tubes optique ont fait
une incision au niveau des ovaires et
par aspiration on prélèvera le vul on
aura bien sûr avant calculer l'heure
précise à laquelle il faut prélever
l'ovocyte murs destinés à être fécondée
trop tôt il n'est pas fait condamnable
trop tard il a disparu selon certaines
études sur trois jours de vue là sion la
femme ne serait fécondables qu'une heure
par mois environ deux heures avant la
coelioscopie le mari a donné son sperme
on a prélevé une partie de ce sperme on
l'a placé dans un tube stérile et on va
le diluer avec un milieu de culture
adéquat
l'agitation permet d'obtenir un mélange
homogène du sperme et du milieu de
culture ensuite on va placer ce tube
dans la centrifugeuse on va le faire
tourner à 1000 tours à la minute pendant
10 minutes de façon à ce que les
spermatozoïdes se déposent au fond du
tube ceci a pour but d'éliminer le
liquide du sperme qui empêche la qualité
fécondante des spermatozoïdes
à la suite de la centrifugation les
spermatozoïdes se sont déposées au fond
du tube et on va éliminer tout le
liquide qui surnage
il reste seulement un très petit dépôt
qui contient à la fois les
spermatozoïdes vivant et les
spermatozoïdes morts on va déposer
délicatement un peu de liquide de
culture de telle façon que les
spermatozoïdes vivant se déplace dans ce
liquide de culture ainsi on obtiendra
une certaine concentration de
spermatozoïdes qui permettra ensuite en
plaçant le vos sites dans ce milieu
d'opérer la fécondation in vitro on va
maintenant placer ce tube dans une
enceinte spéciale à 37 degrés
et l'avait attendre une demi-heure qu'un
nombre suffisant de spermatozoïdes
vivent soient passées dans le milieu de
culture
après une demi-heure d'incubation dans
la couveuse on compte à l'aide du micro
scope binoculaire le nombre des
spermatozoïdes qui sont passés dans le
liquide de culture le jour où nous avons
filmé bruno lassalle en a compté cinq
cent mille par mille litres ce qui
correspond à la concentration la plus
favorable pour assurer une fécondation
aussitôt après la fonction folliculaire
au cours de la coelioscopie le liquide
d'aspiration du follicule est introduit
dans un incubateur à 37 degrés et
stérile dans lequel vont s'effectuer
toutes les manipulations on commence par
vider le contenu de la seringue c'est à
dire le liquide folliculaire dans une
boîte de culture stérile et on va
rechercher dans cette boîte l'ovocyte
qui normalement devrait avoir été
entraînée par l'aspiration du liquide le
voit bien
ou bien alors on va procéder au rinçage
de cet autre site c'est à dire qu'on va
le débarrasser du liquide folliculaire
qui l'entourent puisque ce liquide
serait défavorable à la fécondation
voilà le beau site est aspiré dans la
pipette on le place dans le milieu de
culture qui est toujours le milieu de
menezo et immédiatement on va de nouveau
inspiré ces toxiques dans la pipette
afin de le placer en fécondation dans le
tube que nous avions préparé tout à
l'heure qui contient déjà des
spermatozoïdes vivent
toutes les manipulations se font à 37
degrés si bien qu'il n'y a pas de choc
thermique aussi bien sur les
spermatozoïdes que sur l'ovule
voilà le mariage va commencer maintenant
nouveau site devrait être fécondée par
les spermatozoïdes d'ici une à trois
heures environ on va le remettre dans le
circuit de gazage qui permet de
maintenir l'acidité du milieu et on va
placer ce tube donc il contient
spermatozoïdes et ovules dans une boîte
noire puisque dans l'abdomen il fait
noir et qu'on essaie de respecter au
maximum les conditions naturelles
c'est seulement une douzaine d'heures
après ce moment qu'on va de nouveau
observé l'eau le site qu'on va le rincer
pour le placer dans un nouveau milieu de
culture dépourvu de spermatozoïdes cette
fois et dans ce nouveau milieu de
culture qui est toujours à base du
milieu de menezo on va opérer la culture
de l'embryon pendant trois jours au bout
de trois jours l'embryon devrait si tout
s'est bien passé se trouvait au stade de
8 cellules et à ce moment là on peut le
réimplanter
et pour la femme commence alors la
grande aventure de l'inconnu lorsque le
l'embryon et donc si ce service est
l'une donc procédé à la transplantation
qui doit être un acte simple et c'est
pourquoi
le réalisons en salle de consultation
une consultation qui est prêt de près de
la chambre où séjourne la femme
et ça se fait dans un cadre le moins
médicalisé possible c'est pour ça que
nous mettons de la musique et on essaye
de créer une atmosphère un peu de
détente on va rechercher donc cet
embryon de 6 à 8 cellules à la loupe
binoculaire
c'est une phase qui est toujours un peu
angoissante puisqu'il faut le retrouver
à l'aide d'un matériel très simple qui
sert habituellement pour les
inséminations artificielles
on va donc procéder à l'aspiration de 7
ans brillant dans très peu de liquide
ensuite on procédera à la réimplantation
c'est-à-dire l'introduction de ce petit
cathéter à l'intérieur de l'utérus une
fois qu'on sera à l'intérieur on pourra
pousser simplement la seringue et ainsi
déposé l'an brillant sur la muqueuse
utérine
qui est préparée pour recevoir